alors tu es prêt on va passer aux
questions qu'on ah d'accord on est ça ok
d'accord tu es prêt là
tu préfères Staline ou Hitler
parce que je me sens plus concept
tu dois partir 3 ans dans un vaisseau
spatial tu es prêt là tu préfères Dave
Hervé Vilard ou Patrick Juvet
je peux en prendre deux comme ça il
s'occupe
faire l'amour avec une fille très très
laide ou un mec très très beau
une fille très très laide ah bon quand
même à lui les mecs
à qui trouves-tu le plus de
circonstances atténuantes Jacques Pradel
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tape sur des vieilles
des petites de quel âge à peu près 12 13
ans quoi
[Musique]
un jeune qui tape sur une vieille dans
la vie de la vieille a déjà été faite
elle a eu déjà des joies
tandis que la jeune tu lui niques tout
de suite à 12 ans sa vie bon c'est
question con hein
bien sûr
ça disons la vie le mot le plus con en
amour merci encore oui oui
merci merci
toi aussi tu penses
que tu choisis pas de bouffe ou pas de
cul
un jeu
tout de suite
c'est
prendre quand même pas le papier tu
bouges pas beaucoup alors qu'est-ce que
tu prends pas de bouffe
[Musique]
tu préfères être réincarner en berger
allemand setter irlandais ou épagneul
breton
la bombe arrive dans 5 minutes tu fais
quoi
je continue l'interview je suis un
professionnel
est-ce que tu accepterais d'échanger toi
d'échanger une paralysie générale
contre la fin de la fin en Somalie et au
Soudan et au soudain et au Soudan elle
est le Mali allez tu es paralysé jusqu'à
la fin de tes jours allongé sur un lit
légumes et ces gens là mangent à leur
faim d'accord pas encore pendant tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps tout
le temps et tout mais il y a toujours
des impôts en France
le Soudan et le Mali non non tu veux pas
non non je continue à courir et
ça
un fauteuil
tu préférerais mourir comment rayon
laser bombe à neutrons ou gaz inodore
c'est bien
c'est tout bien la marque
ouais donc
ouais n'importe quoi je m'en fous rayon
laser ça fait un peu sucré
chez toi tu lui apprendrais tu as fermé
le gaz tu as pensé à la capote ou coco
arrête la coco
t'as pensé à la capote tu as pensé à la
capote tu auras un perroquet qui dirait
ça
est-ce que tu préférerais je t'avais le
choix être cul-de-jatte ou impuissant
comme ça j'ai des couilles qui traînent
partout
tout le monde donc tu préfères
impuissant non si c'est possible je
préférerais
vous et mettez un pouce bleu